[MUSIC PLAYING]
People share stories with me
all the time that they've had
an ʻukulele sitting in their
closet for years, and years,
and years, and they've
never taken it out.
So take that ʻukulele
out of the closet.
Let's play some music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I started playing the ʻukulele
when I was 4 years old.
I remember the first time I
picked it up and played it,
I was just overwhelmed
with this joy.
Till this day, every time I
pick up my ʻukulele and play,
I mean, it's that same joy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's something
about this instrument
that brings out this
childlike quality in everyone.
And who doesn't want to feel
like a kid again, right?
And I promise you, if you have
a couple of fingers to spare
and you know how to
count, you will learn
how to play this instrument.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh, that sounds so good.
I love it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The beautiful thing about
the ʻukulele lies in its
simplicity.
You have four strings, you
have two octaves to work with,
and that's it.
Just take your finger and put it
in the bottom left-hand corner
like that, you know?
And that's your first chord.
It's a C7 chord.
And then all you do,
is you jump up a string
and that's your F chord.
And with that, you can
play hundreds of songs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I mean, literally,
hundreds of songs.
Utilizing a tremolo
technique can be difficult,
but it can give
you that illusion
of the note sustaining
over a chord,
or for a duration of time.
There's a magical
thing that happens
when you're holding
an instrument,
and connecting with
it, and making a sound.
It's like therapy for me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Music, I think, has the power
to truly shape who you are.
And I hope that people
will discover through this
MasterClass that the ʻukulele is
not just a tool to make music,
but it's something that
can be life-changing.
Aloha, I'm Jake Shimabukuro,
and this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]